anybody watching this you may not even
know it you all have a why everybody has
a what passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it but when you meet
other people you need to bring an
enthusiasm and an energy to that
question what do you do what's that
belief nation it's heaven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world
now I started the belief life series
every week to try to tackle a different
topic in personal development for you to
absorb sit with learn a little bit about
yourself and hopefully build a better
life for yourself so let's live our best
believe life and discover today how to
find your why enjoy
[Music]
all right to kick things off let's talk
about why this is important
with Patrick Bateman anybody watching
this you may not even know it you all
have a why everybody has a wide the
challenge with some people majority
people's why is it doesn't graduate so
you're why needs to evolve
everyone's why goes through the four
phases your first level of why is what
survival the next vote what I mean by
survival everybody who has a job that
makes money makes money why to survive
and pay the bills but that is there why
so unless you find a way to graduate
that then it's the next level what's the
next of you know I want to make six
figures why status I make six figures I
have a nice car I have a house I have
the same car I'm having a good school
I'm going to a place I got this I got
that so it's status keeping up with the
Joneses it's still lightweight but it's
still a better y than survival the third
one is freedom you know what I'm so sick
and tired of six figures and I want to
be free I want to make money I want to
go out I'm not worried about working
hard I want to make money and I want to
have freedom I want to have breathing
room what do I need to do to have
breathing room that's the next level
because then at that point you're not
necessarily doing it for somebody else
you're doing it because you're wise
gradual you know what I want to be free
I want to live in that community because
I want my kids to play outside and not
have to worry about anything for me I
won't have a big back here because I
want my kids to run or not have to worry
about anything for me for my family I
want to be free so this is somewhat
selfish nothing wrong with it but it's
not the highest level the highest level
is purpose now what are we talking about
purpose what is your why I'll talk to
some people understand my why's I want
to one day on a football team I mean
it's still empty that's still empty I
want to one day on a basketball team
that people ask me Pat all you wonder
you know on a sports team of course
that's in the plans if the opportunity
comes I think I'd make a very good
sports owner I'm fascinated by stats
sports improvement competition it's just
as fascinating but is that really the
purpose of making billions of dollars
and making money no there's got to be a
bigger purpose so how does one
go from survival status freedom purpose
what is truly your purpose
now let's get to the how coming up rule
number one is find the things you do for
free with simon Sinek passion is not an
actionable word it's correct you know
that those who do the things that
they're passionate about do better but
it's not helpful advice and so the
question is where does passion come from
passion is a result passion as an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know and I think
we mistake that passion is something we
do in our private lives but it shouldn't
be done you know in our careers for
example and I'm a firm believer that you
are who you are and anybody who says I'm
different at home than I am at work and
one of those two places you're lying and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home and it works something that you
have excitement to do so how do you find
the things that you're excited to do
well it's actually easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling and and be pay for it so
what are the things that I do in the
weekend right I love I'm very involved
in the art world I love to go to museums
and galleries but I love to go see dance
and performances because I want to see
how others are interpreting the world so
that inspires me new ideas new thoughts
new ways of looking at the world are
things that interest me privately and I
seek it out and pay money for it right
so does that mean I have to have a
career in the arts no it means I have to
have a career where new ideas are
explored where people are experimenting
and trying things out and I have to
explore new ideas and try things out and
I'm just as excited to go to work
everyday as I am to you know go do
something on a Saturday night and so the
idea of finding your passion is
ironically simple because you should be
doing stuff that you enjoy sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
are the people that you love and what
are those where they all have in common
rule number two is do a joy revue with
Jack Canfield another technique you can
use to help you identify your purpose
is to conduct what I call a joy review
simply set aside about 30 minutes and
take the time to go back over your life
and make a list of all the times you
felt the greatest joy in your life now
when I did this I down when I was a
patrol leader in the Boy Scouts when I
was an officer in my military high
school when I was a summer camp
counselor at a camp in Maine my years as
a leader of my college fraternity my
years as a high school teacher and when
I was conducting workshops and training
as a teacher trainer when I was telling
jokes and telling stories when I was
traveling and then look for a pattern
among all these times you've written
down in my case it was when I was
teaching and when I was inspiring and
empowering people to go for their dreams
and they have more love joy and
abundance in their lives and since we
know that joy is part of your internal
guidance system it tells you when you're
on course to the fulfillment of your
innate purpose you can begin to
determine a lot about your life purpose
from completing this joy review rule
number three is try different things
with Owen cook there's really only a few
key areas where we have almost like a
superpower okay aptitudes all right I
guess we could call it a super aptitude
and we're looking for those super
aptitudes all the time by trying out
different lanes alright so take myself
I'm somebody who has attention deficit
disorder and what that means is that I
can speak almost indefinitely it means
that I also have almost infinite
creativity and that also comes from
growing up with depression when you're
depressed that could oftentimes trigger
this very very intense creativity so
between having depression and attention
deficit disorder and also of my case if
you look at things like growing up
unable to read social cues you have an
interesting recipe for how I build real
social dynamics okay so I basically
found my super aptitudes because by not
understanding something so thoroughly I
had to break it down so deeply to
understand it that's social dynamics
which creates great content plus I'm
eating depressed creates creativity and
also having a DD allows me to talk
forever because I don't feel the passage
of time in the way that a normal person
does I can't feel time passing so I
could do this forever okay so if you
look at that that created a super
aptitude
okay now how did I find it I tried out
many different things as long as I was
trying out different things I was happy
so try it out one thing try to another
thing try to the other thing try to
another thing try to another thing now
once I basically realized okay this is
something that I could have a you know
like a lane could open up for me in this
what I did was I committed to a pretty
large degree but still kept different
lanes open and then when I finally
decided that this is what I want to do I
burned the boats
okay in other words got rid of all other
options to sail home and committed 100%
rule number four find what makes your
heart race with Charlie Hooper
what makes your heart race right what
things in your life do you have that
when you engage in that activity your
heart rate literally elevates and as I
look back on my own life one of the very
clear things for me was social
interaction I was a very shy kid
whenever I'd meet someone new that would
kind of make me anxious but particularly
there was someone that I wanted to be my
friend or if it was a girl that I liked
man my heart rate would you shoot
through the roof so reflect on your own
life what sort of things do you have and
again start flipping you can write
scary-movie skydiving whatever it is but
start to go down that list and make a
list of things that actually genuinely
excite you and you know it because your
body is responded and the whole point of
this exercise is that tease out the
things in your life that you care about
but you might be hiding from yourself
because a very very common phenomenon in
today's world is that we have these
things that are core to our identity in
my case it was writing it was social
interaction but they were afraid to
share with the rest of the world because
it is so important to us we're afraid to
make it our profession or even just a
hobby right if you were to write about
it on a blog in the Internet or engage
with it in some other way so go through
this list write see if there are
commonalities things that are so
important to you things that you
legitimately care about that you can get
more involved in and the reason is not
just for yourself because of course
that's going to improve your quality of
life but when you meet other people you
need to bring an enthusiasm and an
energy to that question what do you do
and right now if all you have going is a
job that you're not super into and
friends that you know you like but
you're not crazy about and hobbies that
we're now football on Sundays that is
not going to help you connect with the
kind of people that you want to have in
your life
when you're passionate about something
you will attract other people into their
into your life that have similar
passions and they're maybe in some cases
have passions that are completely
divergent but the intensity of those
passions attract one another and will
number fire the last one before the
bonus clips is serve others with me most
people live their life like this they're
all over the place and they're unhappy
but when you know what your passion is
when you know what your purpose is your
life is a lot easier right you know who
you're supposed to hang out with and who
not to you know what opportunities to
take and which ones not to every
decision becomes easier and you're
living a life that is purposeful that is
happy you're adding value you're helping
people and you feel good and I want that
for everybody so how do you find it you
got to remember that your purpose is
gonna be a combination of something that
makes you happy with something that adds
a lot of value to other people's lives
you are happiest when you're serving
other people we are we are born and
meant to serve others right we feel
happy when we're helping somebody else
out with something and this can be
through a business or can be through
your job or whatever it is but you will
find your greatest pleasure and
happiness when you're adding value to
somebody's life so the combination of
what you love doing something that you
love doing so much something you you
wake up but you know say 9:00 in the
morning you start to work it's you look
down you look back up in a six at night
like we're did where did everything go
where did the time go
because you're so in love with what
you're doing so think about all the
things that you love doing that you can
get lost in and then think about how you
combine that to help other people when
you can merge those two things together
that's when you find your purpose that's
when you find your path the things that
you love doing with the things that help
with the people that combination is
unique to you and when you find it
you'll feel amazing your life will
change everything will change
now I've got three special bonus clips
for you on how to find your wine but
before getting to those my question of
the day is have you found your why yes
or no and if it's a yes what is it
I'd love to hear from you leave it down
in the comments below and if it's a no
then put no - you're on your journey and
I'm excited to see how you eventually
will grow and find it thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clips
so I'd like to share with you a simple
process that can help you identify your
life purpose in as little as 5 to 10
minutes now the process involves
answering three questions and it's
important to write down your answers so
for now just write down the questions
now these also appear in the success
principles book as success principle
number two be clear why you're here so
I'll repeat the questions twice you
write them down and then you can answer
them first ask yourself what are two
qualities that I most enjoy expressing
in life again what are two qualities
that I most enjoy expressing in life now
for me it would be love and joy for my
wife its authenticity and spontaneity
for one of the clients I just worked
with it's discipline and order and for
another one it's fun and play now the
second step is to ask yourself what are
two ways I most love or enjoy expressing
those qualities when interacting with
others again that's what are two ways I
most love or enjoy expressing those
qualities when interacting with others
now for me it's inspiring people with
stories like those in the Chicken Soup
for the Soul books and empowering people
by teaching them practical tools for
creating greater success in their life
through my live trainings online
trainings coaching books DVDs
teleseminars and video blogs like the
one I'm doing right now with you and
finally ask yourself what would the
world look like if it were perfect right
now according to me what would people be
doing how would people be interacting
what would be happening so again that's
what would the world look like if it
were perfect right now according to me
that's you of course now for me it would
be that everyone was living their
highest vision of their most fulfilling
life you see I believe that every single
person is like a cell in a human body
and it takes all kinds of cells and
every cell doing what it's meant to do
for the whole body to work correctly
we need eyeball cells and stomach cells
and knee-joint cells and foot cells and
bone cells and brain cells all of those
have to be working and similarly I
believe that it takes every human being
doing what they were meant to do for all
of humanity to work you see once you
have answers to these three questions
you can combine them into a single
statement now when I put all three of
mine together my life purpose ends up
being to inspire and empower people to
live their highest vision in a context
of love and joy in harmony with the
highest good of all concerned now when
you put yours together you're gonna get
a life purpose statement for you now
once you have that I want you to ask
yourself the next question on a scale of
one to ten how actively am i living my
life purpose again on a scale of one to
ten how actively am I currently living
my life purpose and if your answer is
anything less than a ten then I want you
to ask yourself what would have to
happen to make it a ten what would I
have to do or change to make it attempt
now the answer is do you come up with
are the action steps you need to take so
that you can begin living your purpose
on a day-to-day level everybody has a
calling and your real job in life is to
figure out as soon as possible what that
is who you were meant to be and begin to
honor that in the best way possible for
yourself we have seen over the years on
The Oprah Show so many people who've
been able to rise to success in their
life and only able to rise to success
because they answered the call lots of
people think that it's about being
famous or about being known or about
doing big big incredible things what
you're gonna hear today and see through
the stories is that sometimes the
calling is right in your own
neighborhood
sometimes the calling is something that
was just a whisper to you and when you
begin to honor that whisper and to
follow that you end up being the best
that you could be so in my own life I
have to say the
I had no idea that I would end up being
who I have become but I had a strong
belief that the calling was something
greater than what Mississippi was
showing me the calling was greater than
my front yard the calling was greater
than what my grandmother believed that
my life could be discovering your why is
just the beginning in order to enjoy all
the benefits of having a clearly
articulated why you'll need to have the
courage and discipline to use it like
Thomas Edison said vision with that
execution is hallucination there is an
ideal order for implementing your why
though sometimes reality does get in the
way and it all starts with you our
natural tendency is to start with the
tangible we define our value by what we
do so it takes practice to start with
why like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over we have to really
concentrate we may even fall over even
scrape our knees but we get back on the
bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with Y is no different at first
it feels awkward it may not even work
but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle in time your
Y will act as a filter for many of the
decisions and choices you make it
becomes a tool to help you find a job or
seize an opportunity in which you're
more likely to succeed it removes a lot
of the guessing here's a metaphor to
show you what I mean it's called the
celery test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it it's like going to a dinner
party and somebody says do you know what
you need you need M&Ms we've done so
well with M&Ms you've got to use M&Ms
somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us Kit Kats you
have to use Kit Kats and somebody else
says to you it's all about celery we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant
case studies and we buy everything we've
I'd kick cats and M&Ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout line
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why let's imagine our wise to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense
we spend less time and less money at the
supermarket and when we're standing
there in line with only celery and only
rice milk now people can see what we
believe somebody walking past can say
hey I can see that you're healthy so am
I you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend simply by saying
and doing the things that you believe
and the best part is its scalable as
soon as I said the Y you knew exactly
which products we were going to buy this
means the more you can articulate your
why the more others will know what you
stand for and will be able to help you
make the right decisions from now on you
will work to ensure everything you do is
a good fit if you do too many things
that aren't a good fit you'll feel
uncomfortable and people will feel that
you're being inauthentic on the other
hand when you start with Y your ability
to stand out find support and work to
all your natural strengths will flourish
with practice you will learn to trust
your Y you will eventually start to see
your job and the things you do as ways
to breathe life into your cause and the
better you get at it the more you will
feel that your life and everything you
do has purpose the best way to implement
your Y is to work at it slowly you don't
have to do all the tips we suggest what
is important is that you pick up 2/3 and
commit to practicing and using them now
raise your standard Apple at the pool
core value is that we believe that
people have passion and change the way
people now one drop of my self-worth
depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details